One example, where SDN can provide huge wins, is in the data center. A
data center, typically consists of many racks
of servers. And any particular cluster might
have, as many as 20,000 servers. Assuming that each one of these servers can
run about 200 virtual machines. That's 400,000
virtual machines in a cluster. A significant
problem is provisioning or migrating these
virtual machines in response to varying
traffic loads. SDN solves this problem by programming the switch state from a
central database. So supposing, I have
two virtual machines within the data center
that needs to communicate with one
another. The forwarding state in the switches,
in the data center ensures that traffic is forwarded correctly. If we need to
provision additional virtual machines. Or migrate a
virtual machine from one server to another in
the data center, the state in these
switches must be updated. Updating the state in
this fashion is much easier to do,
from a central controller or a central database,
facilitating. This type of Virtual Machine Migration
in the data center is one of
the early killer apps of software-defined networking.
This type of migration is also made
easier by the fact that the servers are addressed with Layer two Addressing. And
the entire data center Looks like a flat layer two topology. What this means,
is that a server can be migrated from one portion of the data center to another
without requiring the virtual machine to obtain new
addresses. All that needs to happen for forwarding to
work ,is the state of these switches. Needs
to be updated. The task of updating switch
date in this fashion is very easy to
do, when the control and data plans are separate.